President Trump is having a series of
high-stakes meetings with European
allies in Belgium he is about to meet
with Frances newly elected president and
Manuel McCraw after talking with other
leaders at the European Union
headquarters Margaret Brennan is
traveling with the president in Brussels
where he will soon attend the first NATO
gathering Margot good morning good
morning well America is often seen as
the leader of the NATO military alliance
which was originally founded to counter
Russian power in Europe today president
Trump will urge them to focus more on
counterterrorism thousands demonstrated
against president Trump's arrival in
Brussels a city he once described as a
hellhole protesters unveiled an
unwelcome message nearby the u.s.
embassy president Trump's criticism of
key institutions like the European Union
which he has argued should be dissolved
made for a highly charged first
encounter with its leaders he'll try for
a fresh start at NATO a military
alliance that during the campaign he
said could be broken up its obsolete and
we're paying too much money since the
election he's had to change apart I said
it was obsolete it's no longer obsolete
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson said
yesterday that the president still
believes NATO members need to spend more
on their own defence I think you can
expect the President to be very tough on
them I don't say look the u.s. is
spending 4% we're doing a lot in the
wake of the Manchester attack NATO plans
to formally join the Obama era coalition
against Isis counterterrorism has been a
theme throughout mr. Trump's Trevi I
repeat again that we must drive out the
terrorists and the extremists from our
myths obliterate this evil ideology the
president is also requesting more NATO
forces join the roughly 8400 US troops
in Afghanistan mr. Trump and his closest
advisors are still debating the
Pentagon's recommendation to expand the
u.s. role and add up to 5,000 US troops
Trump administration officials say they
are still a couple of weeks away when it
comes to that decision on the u.s. role
in Afghanistan a 16 year conflict that's
already America's longest war gale
president Trump flies tonight for more
meetings with world leaders at the g7
summit in Sicily
all right thank you Margaret Brennan
reporting from Brussels